la cop27 la grande conférence des
Nations Unies sur le climat débute ce
week-end dans l'Egypte beaucoup de pays
ont adopté des cibles très ambitieuses
pour réduire leurs émissions polluantes
mais peu ont trouvé la clé pour les
Athènes aujourd'hui on vous emmène au
Pays-Bas où ce sont les tribunaux qui
ont ordonné au gouvernement de respecter
ces engagements en matière
d'environnement et vous allez le voir
pour le fleuron national qui est
l'agriculture les impacts sont énormes
une opération escargot sur un grand axe
routier aux Pays-Bas l'été dernier les
tracteurs provoquent des bouchons
monstres sur l'autoroute la colère des
agriculteurs s'étale c'est un plan
dévoilé au mois de juin qui a mis le feu
aux poudres le pays devra diminuer de
50% ses rejets d'azote d'ici 2030 pour y
arriver le gouvernement a annoncé qu'il
faudrait réduire de près du tiers le
nombre d'animaux d'élevage
dans un pays aux profondes racines
agricoles la nouvelle crée une commotion
tout au long de l'été les manifestations
se succèdent
[Musique]
trinkelsoft est productrice laitière et
travaille aussi pour le plus grand
syndicat agricole des Pays-Bas avec son
mari elle possède une ferme de 250
vaches
nous les fermiers nous comprenons qu'il
faut faire une transition mais 2030
c'est beaucoup trop rapide
alors que le reste du monde parle de
réduire ses émissions de carbone ici
l'urgence c'est aussi de limiter les
émissions azotées ironiquement l'azote
est utile aux plantes on leur en donne
sous forme d'engrais ou de fumier mais
quand il y en a trop ils deviennent
nuisibles l'excès peut créer par exemple
du protoxyde d'azote un gaz à effet de
serre au pouvoir réchauffant 300 fois
supérieur au CO2 les déjections animales
produisent aussi de l'ammoniac un gaz
qui n'entraîne pas le réchauffement de
la planète mais qui pollue
les algues bleues et les particules
fines c'est beaucoup à cause de lui
au Pays-Bas le secteur agricole est
responsable de plus de 60% des émissions
d'azote l'objectif du gouvernement et de
s'attaquer rapidement aux fermes les
plus polluantes Hadès
à court terme le gouvernement nous dit
qu'il faudra éliminer de 500 à 600
fermes
l'État devra les acheter pour qu'elle ne
produisent plus
[Musique]
le gouvernement a débloqué près de 25
milliards d'euros pour accélérer la
transition mais pour les agriculteurs
qui n'ont aucune intention d'arrêter
comme le mari de trinque cette somme ne
suscite aucun enthousiasme
regardez mes bouches en verre green
[Musique]
les détails de la réduction pour chaque
région ne sont pas encore connues mais
la ferme des elstroff est
particulièrement visée car elle est
située à peine un kilomètre de l'une des
rares réserves naturelles des Pays-Bas à
proximité de ces zones les émissions
azotées devront diminuer non pas de 50
mais de 70% pour préserver la
biodiversité des lieux l'une des options
suggérées et de réduire le nombre
d'animaux par fermes ce qui ne s'annonce
pas simple
nous en avons 250 en ce moment mais si
on en garde que 200 par exemple on a
encore les coûts pour tout le bâtiment
les emprunts à la banque il va falloir
faire des calculs on ne sait pas si ce
sera possible
pour les Pays-Bas c'est une formidable
volte-face après avoir souffert de la
fin pendant la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
les Néerlandais se sont dit plus jamais
et ils ont tenu parole ce pays minuscule
de 17 millions d'habitants est
aujourd'hui le deuxième exportateur
agricole en valeur au monde après les
Etats-Unis et le cheptel national
reflète cette réalité c'est la plus
forte densité d'animaux d'élevage de
l'Europe 4 millions de bovins 12
millions de ports 100 millions de poulet
sont exportés mais le fumier reste ici
c'est ça le problème
notre secteur agricole est beaucoup trop
important nos champs n'ont pas la
capacité d'absorber tout ça
ce professeur retraitait de la plus
grande université agricole du pays
explique qu'on a trop tardé à agir
dans les années 70 il était déjà évident
que notre agriculture générait beaucoup
de pollution et émettait trop d'azotées
d'autres éléments
les premières politiques pour résoudre
le problème date des années 80 mais
elles ont été un échec
aujourd'hui les niveaux de pollution
azotées sont les plus élevés de toute
l'Europe mais malgré l'urgence beaucoup
d'agriculteurs réclament plus de temps
pour s'adapter selon eux la solution
viendra de la technologie
les vaches à la main avec un seau
aujourd'hui beaucoup de mes collègues
utilisent des robots de traite alors
donnez-nous le temps et on pourra y
arriver et vous faites
[Musique]
les Néerlandais sont effectivement des
champions de l'innovation agricole mais
compte tenu de la taille du cheptel bien
des scientifiques sont d'avis que ce ne
sera pas suffisant
depuis le début on a pensé qu'avec la
technologie et l'agriculture de
précision on allait éliminer les
émissions
honnêtes avec le recul on constate que
ça ne marche pas
les niveaux de pollution sont elles
qu'une boule de projets sont bloqués ce
qui a un impact sur toute la société
[Musique]
beaucoup de maisons ne peuvent pas être
construites parce que ça aussi ça émet
de l'azote
alors imaginez vous êtes un citoyen des
Pays-Bas et vous ne pouvez pas vous
bâtir une maison parce que les émissions
azotées sont trop élevées dans le pays
une autre option évoquée pour les
fermiers néerlandais c'est le passage à
l'agriculture bio donc une moins grande
densité d'animaux pas d'engrais
chimiques et l'accès aux pâturages ce
qui génère beaucoup moins d'ammoniac
pour trinquer dans les deux fils
voudraient reprendre la ferme la réalité
d'aujourd'hui est aux antipodes de celle
qu'elle a connu il y a quelques
décennies à peine
nous sommes passés de 140 à 250 vaches
en 30 ans la ferme pouvait grossir se
développer nos enfants eux doivent
penser à réduire à réduire c'est très
différent
depuis longtemps le cheptel du pays
n'est pas autosuffisant il n'y a tout
simplement pas d'espace ici pour faire
pousser assez de nourriture pour toutes
ces bêtes le seuil a par exemple est
importé massivement d'Amérique du Sud
une autre raison selon plusieurs de
revoir ce modèle d'agriculture intensive
il faut produire en tenant compte des
limites des écosystèmes importés de la
moulée restez pris avec le lisier tout
en disant qu'on nourrit le monde alors
qu'en fait on se retrouve avec un
environnement pollué ce n'est pas de
manière durable de faire de
le rêve de nourrir le monde à partir
d'un tout petit nombre d'hectares ça n'a
aucun sens
[Musique]